this is your first film as a director
and writer now what have you learned
from the other directors that you fought
with us prosthetics and special makeup
artist on their set fret just do your
homework do your prep think about every
little detail everything you can go on
everything that will go on how to adapt
and yes more about preparation and
vision has the two things I always feel
their overloads preparation and vision
now you guys have worked together of
course before but it's Paul of being
apathetic artist at a time what's it
like working him is working with him as
a director Sean I'm very similar in many
respects because that he Paul gets
allocated grown up in time to achieve
his wizardry and that's why I've got
completely confident working the ball on
this project which is a really difficult
subject because I knew he gets given
allocated very little time I've work
with him when I've been rode an hour at
up against a wall and he's been given 15
minutes to get it right so under that
kind of pressure and like he just said
about sort of the prayer brett-brett pro
and the facts of course we had a locked
solid base of the script which is
anyway so I wasn't concerned about that
and and Paul took to it as a duck to
water but I really admired about who is
that that he let a heads of Department
people that normally that directors
tried to orchestrate he let them and
trust them enough to do their job so it
became very much a creative process very
much a company feel now is the film
that's very cross Truffaut big isn't it
and I know kind of made me think in that
sense a film that you worked on before
word neil marshall the descent without
something that influenced you at all
you're making the seasoning house it's a
different kind of story but it has got
same themes claustrophobia tension and
they're three-wide so in that respect
they're quite similar in that respect
but not your subject matter Paul it's
had to kill you a lot of times on camera
before has it here which has been the
best time for you I think being straps
on the a full of truck over a buddy the
gas rub burner and then actually roasted
like a suckling pig and pulled apart
place history or in bile stations and
loads of arrows it's a personal favorite
of mine thanks Paul
working with you which one of you
enjoyed inflicting on in the most Paul
which have you enjoyed inflicting on
Sean the both I actually liked me for
his face off in a fade dog because it's
like a puppet it's just like rip his
face off and it was a very cold and may
need a strap to a treat yeah you guys
have worked individually and together in
loads of british horror films what you
think in the state of british horror and
what's different about british horror
compared to horror from other countries
I mean a lot of british horror films are
made a little bit too low budget it's
minus things would be nice if a little
bit more money will spend longer
schedules you make better films woman in
black was a good example they put their
money and they gave the schedule they
gave their facilities and resources to
make it what it was and willing to make
up you know over a hundred million and
you know too many horror films are just
made my chlobo jutt they're not giving
the budgets and it's a shame like even
look at your returns more than the
product itself and i think this is where
this is slightly different you know it's
not just using as a genre as a stepping
stone to actually make something that
can hurt
that's why we need investments and
that's what exactly right also do you
feel like the young girl Rosie J who's a
star the lead actress in this film do
you think she's a real discovering that
she'll go on big time here and I
discovered her after looking through a
hundred sweaty girls I found her she's
absolutely brilliant she going to go on
to such big things boy she liked to act
with Shawn brilliant I mean she's nails
have you seen the sizable she's that big
and she was getting through a slot Paul
show me I can't believe it I thought she
was a contortionist through a slot like
this that's the thing it's not my I hard
but at least in cavernous great big
aluminium shafts with even scuttle about
seems going through gaps like this and
it's unbelievable what she put a body
through but not only that I've distress
is how brilliant as I haven't been an
actress years the to be a prisoner
within a prison is no mean feat to be
it's apparently unaffected by what's
going on it's extraordinary difficult
feat and she's brilliant she's
absolutely brilliant what's next to you
guys now Susan house is part one of a
war theme Tommy trilogy but yes i'll
just try to work out one good you next
the black site was something you had as
a teaser trailer here last year wasn't
that was going to be the first one
that's part of it isn't it was with the
trilogy always what you had in mind it
happened organically how did it work out
this guy was going to do black site
first but we needed quite a bit more
money it was over two million so we
thought we'd do season house which is
slightly nests but hopefully black site
maybe my next one I'm working on TV
series with jean reno at the moment the
lady that directed the killing and the
bridge so i'm working with the Magness
arena which is terrifying nice breeze
just extraordinary keen with a legends
you know so i really can't complain
you're a big fan of all those shows yeah
very much so I doing so Nordic new army
actually it's not dissimilar from what
Paul is doing here it's got the same
feel and quality do you think makes us
stand out because obviously they've been
so popular they're really kind of having
a moment with Scandinavian TV and film
at the moment aren't they attention and
style is by what I would say the
intention it the idiot adhere to the
attention to the script and the style
they're completely comfortable in
because then it accomplishes the world
and then you believe you did a lot of
film initially in slow motion did you
there's a lot of Steadicam work as well
and it changes how is that a shooting
that was a first time director Paul and
how is it as an actor as well as Sean
working a lot with Steadicam basically
that the snow mode of Steadicam was
communicator feel of a dreamy as
hypnotic kind of perspective of losing
so for me as it's great I I loved it how
about you Sean we were working with this
fantastic guy Adam who is our DB and
operator he's got shoulders of Hercules
I mean it wasn't really even Steadicam
was it I mean it was he's like a sort of
a pea way he's extraordinary so you the
quality I haven't seen the film now is
different and the style your apps
right when the real world arrives the
shape of me there is a marked difference
between the opium well as of rosy day of
angel and when our winner
wenger on arrives there's a marked
difference but it didn't affect the way
that we approached the world you're very
you're very unaware of them they spoke
they're all the crew were extraordinary
they worked at such moods it was
breathtaking and effect i think is
extraordinary and i'm very very very
very proud
you